Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to-
*does octodad impression*
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to "Dead End Road".
Now I found this horror game and it looked very interesting because it was kind of a...
pseudo-pixelated style?
I have no idea how it's gonna play, I have no idea how it's gonna--
Hello Grandma, how are you doing?
Hohoho, whoa!
"So you've finally arrived my dear?"
Oh have I? "You can come closer if you would like?" I would not like that; I'd like to maintain as much distance
between me and that fucked up face as I possibly can.
Holy shit! "Perhaps my appearance
frightens you?"
You're goddamn right it does! What
happened to your eyes?!
Ugh! "There is no need to be afraid child."
"You seek instruction on the ritual, yes?"
Ok! You know you said there's no need to be afraid *lisps a bit* then you say thing like there's going to be rituals?
And I need instruction for them. I'm not okay with this - this is absolutely absurd.
"That is what my visitors usually ask of me." *Awkward giggle*
OOOOkay! "It is true that the ritual has power..."
"...the power to grant one wish."
"But it comes at a terrible cost"
Ok! What? "I can see you will not be
dissuaded-"
Can you? I'm easily dissuaded; you could just tell me to leave and I'll go.
"Go perform the ritual, then return to me."
"And bring with you the following; A book, a bell and a candle."
Ok?  Alright! A book, a bell and a candle.
"Can you remember that, my dear?" Yeah! A book, a bell and a candle.
I don't know why I need these things but
I'll go get them for you Grandma!
"So then, do you still wish to proceed?"
"Very well"
"Then we shall begin..."
With a book, a bell and a candle.
Oh geez! OH geez! OH GEEZ!
"Perform the ritual with the directional input"
I don't know what I'm doing?!?
What do I?
Ooohh!
Ah!
Whoa!
Did I do it? Do I get my wish now?
Okay!
Ah!
This is bizarre...
Okay?
Oh, okay! I get it: it glows where it supposed to be,
and each of the button[s] controls a
different...
Ok! that's supposed to be there, those two
are supposed to be there...
...and this is supposed to be here!
AHH! There we go!
Okay! Got it, got it, got it! Book, a bell and a candle. Did I get those? Or did I need to get those?
"What is your request of the dark powers?"
Um!
*conflicted groan* How do I subtly wish for a bigger dick?
*Bubble noise*
Uh!
A huge, massive, enor- Uh oh!
Uh! Ok! Uh! Just erase it...
Um...
Ultimate power...
*More conflicted groaning*
A doggo...
A-a a
*Mark.exe is not responding*
A doggo named Fred- Ah fuck it.
Ultimate power!
Bam, bitch! Give it to me! What's the terrible cost?
Oh hey- Whooaa, hey...
Hello! Ah, fuck off with you! I should've had my defense up!
*Sick robot wobs?*
What?
Oh oh. What did I do? Do I have ultimate power?
I don't know. I don't know what I did. I don't know what I did, bruh!
Okay. Alrighty, then. I'm driving in a car now.
Oh, geez.
I love the styling of this game, by the
way. I know it's like, it's low-res, but
it's intentionally low res- oh, geez.
OH, g- OH, geez! OH-h-ho geez!
Oh, geez! Aw, cool
OHH, geez! I'm outta here, baby! I don't know where I'm going, but- whoo, hey!
Oh, this wind that rushes through
these hills...
Oh, boy... OH boy, oh boy. Hello!
ok goodbye Ah! Gonna crash! Oh, geez! I don't know what I'm supposed to be doing with this!
Where am I going? I'm so confused.
And panicked! Hoping that grandma doesn't show up at any moment. She never even- Oh geez, what did I
hit? She never even told me what the
terrible price actually was. Ok, I-I-oooh, woah!
I see that the- the meter-
It's counting down, so I should be
getting- I'm g-whoooo- hey trash can! I-
Ah! Boxes! Okay- oh, s**t.
Oh, jeez. Oh, geez. I'm all over
the road here- Oww, shit! Uh-oh.
Alright. Backing up. Yep. Yep, yep, yepyepyep- okay, let's try that again without dying.
Hopefully, anyway...
Not 100% sure on this- whoa! (Whoa, whoa, whoah...)
Goddamn! Whoa, whoa-w-w-whoa, I didn't know this was
gonna be skill-based!
I don't have a lot of skills, so I don't know how this is gonna work out!
Oh, geez.
Probably shouldn't be going full
throttle...
Oh, G- oh, goddammit, I didn't- ugh!
'Kay, I'm getting close - I'm only 1.5
units away from my destination, I think!
ugh
I don't know what that sign said, but it
was probably important for me to know it...
Okay?
Road got straight.
Okay, almost there!
*whimper*
Okay I did It! A-Averiville
Turn le-okay. I'm going to Averville. The
following shops appear to still be open:
Supermarket, mechanic, pharmacy, pawnshop,
leave. Oh. Thank god some places are still
open at this hour.
Why do I need money? What?
What? *constipated grunts* What am i doing i am so confused
HI!!! WHOA What happened to your EYES?!?!?!
Oh geez! Following items are available.
Let's get some-
'I don't like the way this guy is staring
at me'. Let's get some cigs and get out of
here.
Yeah, let's get them cigarettes, get some chocolate -
don't judge me. I'm- I'm emotional at the
moment. I just summoned a demon and got
ultimate power, so don't *breathes* you mess
with me bro.
Okay, I got stuff I don't know- a scratch
card I guess, I'm not sure. Okay...
Oh-Oh okay, I'm not a winner this time.
I'll give it one more go and then we'll
see what happens...
BINGO! Yeah the winner is me! Is this the
ultimate power finally getting to me?
All right I'm out of here. Alright, I
guess I can go to the mechanic...
Jesus, what is happening here? Oh god! 'I
don't like this guy's attitude' I don't
like any of these guys' face! Ugh! Right, so I
guess I could repair the car, but I don't
know why...
Ooo, hello.
Okay, can I?
Oh geez.
Repair it? All right did that.
It's good I guess... My fuel... Yeah, okay...
Upgrades...
What is this? Bull bars reduce collision
damage?
(Whispers) What the fuck?
This one? All right ok.
(Quietly) This is what I do.. this- this-  this is bizarre.
This is just bizarre.
I don't even know
why this is happening. Aw, it's so weird.
Hello. 'I can feel this guy silently
judging me'
Let's see quaaludes?!? Why is that on here?
I'm out of here, good god! Buh... Alright, pawn shop
Ugh... Hey buddy. 'Following items are available':
Bible, matches, collar Bell
Oh a book, a candle, and a bell! Don't I need a bell?
Wait, do I still need these things? I don't
know if I need these things. I need a
candle.
I-I guess I need this!
Woah jeez. This isn't a candle though.
But I got matches for a candle I suppose.
'There's something I don't like about this
place' -
Well it seemed like a normal supermarket
than a pawn shop...
All right, whatever. I guess I'm gonna
head back now.
Okay where -
Whoa. What the-WHAT?
Oh shit! Is this going back?
Oh, I don't know. I don't know where I'm
going! I don't know what I'm doing!
What the hell is going on here?
Oh jeez, dude
Oh geez du-ooh. Whoa almost hit that...
Oh hello! What was that?
Oh, there's cows on the road!
I am *hesitates*
unbelievably confused. Incredibly
confused.
Hey, what was that? Deep it? Dub it? Do
it? Do what? Do what?! Ah shit.
*vroom vroom screechy car noises*
Uh-oh. Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, hey, whoa, hey, whoa, hey - why
is this happening? Why this is happening
whuh-oh okay. Uhhh...
Oh geez, the road is getting awfully
treacherous - hey whoa what was - that!!
WHAT?!
YOU SUFFERED A FATAL CAR ACCIDENT?!
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESTART?? I don't even know what happened! That
wasn't fatal! What are you talking about??
Oh god damn it! What the fuck??
What happened??
What, did I not get to it???
What the fuck happened??
What?
Eternal life.
So I don't die. *no shit sherlock*
'The dark powers have not understood your request'
(giggles) Whuhut?! giant penor.. well just. BEAUTY!
BEAUTY! Give me beauty! I'm not - boo beyheyughhey, how's it going?
(Demonic Voice) YOU ARE BEYOND THE REACH OF GOD WHILE HERE
"You are beyond the something of God here"
The reach? Maybe? I have no idea. Okay, so now
I'm assuming I need a book, a bell,
and a candle...
to be able to get what I need.
Whoa. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa - what are
you dumping dude? What are you dumping?
Stop that!
What did you just hit me with? Whoa
Ahh, what is that? Oh, was that meat?
Why was there meat?! Why was that thing throwing meat? Eugh, ah, hey, whoa, hokay.
Jeezums. This road is a lot more
treacherous than the first one I went on.
Oh crap.
OH Crap!
Oh hey whoa HI god - goodbye HOLY SHIT! What was THAT?!
Why were you there? That was weird
Oooookay! The fuck happened here!?
Why am I in a tube of meat? Oh geez. That would probably be bad if I was just driving
down the Highway and not able to know where I was going, but thankfully - God why
is all this shit happening now? Because
beauty is a much more... oh geez
Beauty's a much more difficult request to answer. Can I co- can I backup please?
Please? Please?
Oh geez. Okay, I think we reached the
straightaway finally. Which is awfully
nice... oh geez.
What the hell is going on here? I haven't a goddamn clue, but I need a book, a bell, and a
candle! A book, a bell, and a candle would be lovely!
A book, a bell, and a candle!
Averville, Averville!! Okay, supermarket!
Maybe I can try for the scratch card
again...
Boop! Okay that was a waste of money
all right, I'm out of here.
No, not that.
Cowbell!
A math textbook?! That's a book!
That is definitely a book! And a candle...
But a fire lighter isn't exactly what I
needed, but just in case, I'm going to get it
In case I need to light the candle
All right.
So I got a bu- a beh, a boo de beh de boo. All right. I'm
gonna save my money until I get to the
All right. I'm
gonna save my money until I get to the next place.
Okay, so Draughtshire or North Hollows.
I imagine Draughtshire is where I just camefrom, considering I turned left into this place,
but I'm gonna go left here to try to go a ways away, and
I'm gonna go at a very reasonable speed.
Oh, whoa, hey, whoa, see - that's why. Why are these guys driving on random sides of the road?
Seems very inappropriate...
Oh! Was that a body?
Why's there a body in the middle of the street? that didn't make any - go
whoa. Hello!
*demon grumbles*
'I will be down there with you'? Is that
what you're saying? Well ooo, hey
*beepy demon screams*
I think, actually, I just realized,
everything's in pounds. So I think
driving on the left side of the road is
the only a appropriate way to do thi-
I can't see.
Please turn it on!
Hokay, whoa, geez, okay. Well that didn't seem good.
I'm glad that my problems are affecting
the rest of the world and - I can't see a
goddamn thing.
Oh, is that the guy throwing meat again? Oh
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Okay, now we're getting to the heart of
the matter!
Oh jeez. Oh! Fuck me! In the butt! Oh god! Jeez! Hoooly crap!
Can I turn my lights back on, please? Oh
geez, I can control that? Holy crap - hi!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, eyeballs! That's weird!
Hokay, now I'm getting it! okay Oh! Hey, hitchhiker
No. AHH, fuck! Sorry, SORRY, oh god! I'm sorry! I'm sorry!
Okay. *sings* My sanity is not doing well. All right.
Whoa! Holy shit! I'm okay.
What the fucking fucker fuck?
I just want to know - whoa, whoa, whoa, watch out buddy.
Ehh shit. Ahhhhh, I don't know what you said, man!
Okay. Shit. Well that ain't good.
Ahh, bird! Well, that bird had a bad day.
Looks like - I bet I'm having a bad day,
with my car all being beat to shit and no
you do not!
Not throwing any more meat at me! Whoa, what is
that? What was that? Uh
Uh, oh jeez! Well that ain't good!
How do i fix that? Okay, nevermind, it fixed itself!
don't don't . Oh hey...What the hell is happening? I don't much appreciate you being in my backseat!
bitch
ok I think I finally made it to the
straightaway shouldn't got it
I shouldn't get in just in case it's all
interior lights ok ok
what the fuck
yeah
I think I turn on the radio ok
dead end road I started there went to a
marvel
ok for so i need to go
am I trying to go to dead end road
I think I am so if I just keep taking
left out of here i should be able to get
everything I need to get it
the dead end road I think that's my
objective here
ok ok
supermarket
I just need a candle damn it ok for you
darken Ali search
ally during the search of the alley the
only items of interest you find a
discarded needles and a rat knowing on a
rod morsel the resembles a human toe you
decide to discontinue your investigation
the alley
ok all right then I wish I hadn't gone
this way me too me too buddy to buddy
maybe the antique store has something
yeah
grimoire lighter broken Bell a grimoire
of what
Klaatu Barada nikto that seems important
I'll get that - hold out for the candle
i'm pretty sure i don't have that right
just keep driving
just keep driving it's all we can hope
for
I just can't hit anything else because i
think my car's in bad shape
we're going left we're just going to
make left we're gonna be cool
a bird ok
Walker
come to Daddy come to Daddy
no thank you I'm perfectly okay where I
am
oh boy that's ahead hello head
we were just all homeless kid that hole
again after you're okay
I don't know what happened whoa
okay jeez
Okay all right oh geez
yeah i think i think the way the game is
programmed it's not actually uh it's not
actually it's not actually uh any turns
that are on the road
it's not actually any turns that are on
the road the road just randomly shifts
left and right at random intervals
I think that's the way it's programmed
ahh geez
doing fine
and this is a hard road to drive on whoa
that was a body mmmmm
that was tasty body whoa hey buddy woah geeze
oh oh oh oh oh-that's not good
oh that's not good *hooonk* ahhh! whoa
too close can't see a goddamn thing ah! fuck sorry! i'm sorry i'm sorry
oo~ very good my car is about to explooode
dude I don't think I'm gonna make it
I don't think I'm gonna make it whoa
kay avoid that
i'ma drive the middle of the road or at
least try well I think I might of made it
final stretch
god I don't think I have enough money to
repair my car at this point *beautiful singing*
alright Holrich shouldn't of blown all my money on scratch'ems!!
alright let's try the umm- pawn shop see if
there is a candle there
Votive candle! that's what i needed really nice candle thank you! ok so that's good
and let's see if i can actually repair
enough to do any damage but i don't know
all right let's see repair not enough?- ahh! I
need all cash i can't just do a partial repair
god damnit that's gonna be a bitch
well I can't do anything
I don't even think i can buy scratchns
it will be good enough i think im just
fucked~
well might as well try really doladdoladdoladdolad ba-ding! ok
might as well try again there's no risk
in it because otherwise I don't even
think I have enough to do anything
nope not a winner I know I'm unlucky is
this just a baaaad run
bing! ok so no no winners that time but we're fine
don't need to buy anything else but I
got all the supplies so if I can just
make it through I think just one more
town i'm not sure but who knows who
knows I'm probably not gonna make it
not gonna make it nnnot gonna make it cant make it-wont make it cant do it
no it ain't gonna happen buhuhuh *ahh don't complain mark*
alright if I consult my map i'm currently in holrich so it's literally just one more
go until I get to dead-end Road which I
imagine is where I need to go and I've
been very conservative about fuel know
what?
let's try what's the harm we're gonna
happen
dead end road let's do this I'm gonna go
in schnail pace woahh jeez woah jeez this road seems to buhe-mmmm-bad
nail pace you can't beat me!-well you could probably be me
orgies *this is supposed to be woah geeze but im gonna keep it XD*
whoa! ah dammit
one with the fire and such
god damn well okay
uhh hi friend my friend
*creepy ass radio static or whatever o.o*
oh geez
oh jeez did I avoid that okay i think i
did ahh! fucking bird fu-dammit!
oh geez road frigging curving at random
whoa what the hell what is this! warning a
fatal error has occurred what are you
talking about system has no chance to
recover what you're talking about
user has no chance to-woooaaahhh!  ok is that supposed to be my
computer?
I think of a little more advanced than
doss
well that's that's that's best very bad
that's-that-proly-that proly bad that was probably bad ohhbado
hello other car who would be driving on
this road !?who?! just who would be
whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo would tolerate this
road
oh geez I'm not even gonna try to pass this
guy
he seems to be more capable navigator than
I am
oo-ah! *what are we monkeys now?*
gotta listen to the lovely sounds of
this radio station
~~*lovely sound of the radio station*~~
kay im passing him
which is-there we go ok got it
this is flipdickin impossible! fuck woah ge-ahh goodammit
fuck that
woah
*more lovely noises*:D
I met a terrible fate havent I idk maybe maybe i have
*demonic: turn around*
turn around?!  I've gone a bit too far at this point ooooo
maybe I should turn around there ahh!
* fucck that demonic laughing o.o*
uh-oh
wuh-oh wuh-oh!
ohhh noo! goddammit i was so close!
ah fuck oh good it skips ba-ok
this may be good it it skips past the first
part which means that it's going to give
me enough time to do that but damn what
what did I hit
ahh god damn it i think I-uh that might have been
oh god I'm hitting everything fuck me
it's ridiculous
scented candle
that's good I'll get that scented candle
a collar Bell works for me~
lets  see we hav a cat collar good enough
matches maybe i need 'em they're cheap
enough enough i'll get 'em then just a bouk
just book just a book-e-book search ally
with some trepidation you enter some
dark alley as soon as you have entered a
local ne'er do well threatens you and
demands all your-ohhh I lost half my cash!?
fuck you!!
goodamnit kay still afford a book
I think it'll be okay hi didn't I
luckily i've already spent some of my
money so i only need the book left and
then maybe repair and maybe fuel but i
think i have enough to get there we
shall see
just two more hop to go I got more
than half of you left so i think we're
okay if I don't have a book in this next
town i'm basically fucked because i
don't think there's another turn away
until get to the end there so hopefully
please have a book ahhh perfect! i'll
take the Bible
this will be great yes thank you very
much i got everything I needed
I even have matches i have all that shit
and umm.....should be good then I should just be
able to make it all the way to the end
and I should be a-okay right right okay
I think so all right and this time I
just gotta drive really carefully like
slow as a snail
here we go
ohh come on how did i hit something i didnt even see a-woah!
I didn't even see a bird
she's oh god dammit dammit dammit dammit
dammit dammit that was unavoidable
okay good for you i hope you got a big
appetite
you can't swallow all of me fucking
pothole
god damn this is absurd
what oh god damn it it's another one of
these things
yeah this looks like my computer oh boy
think it told me to just tea bag myself
damn
it whoa*X like 6*I'm not hitting you
Wo-geeze ok wow that guy really whoa that
guy really want to splatter himself all
over my car
i think i just missed a bird *hooonk*woaahh hey buddy
ahh fuck
ahhh you cant stop me!
*hoooonk* woah! geezums
what the fuck is that I don't know what
that's about
ooo I don't know what that's about super weird *hooonk* wah-fuck off!!are you kidding me
ahh fuck that god damn it that's such
bullshit
alright so i was having a bout a bad luck
and i just ran out of time
if you guys can figure out how to get to
the end i'll put a link to the game in
the description below you can tell me
about it and maybe i'll try to pick it
up later but I just don't have enough
time right now so thank you everybody so
much for watching
let me know what you think of this in
the comments below and as always I will
see you... in the next video.
Buh bye!